اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في بانوراما يقدمها لكم
اليوم ابراهيم بدر وهذه عناوينها
السودان جوله جديده من الاشتباكات والجيش
يعلن تعليق المفاوضات مع الدعم السريع فهل
عادت الازمه السودانيه الى المربع الاول
بوساطه عمانيه مفاوضات نوويه بين واشنطن
وطهران هل ستزيل الدبلوماسيه عقبات الملف
النووي ام ستزيد من مخاوف وقلق اسرائيل
وسط مخوف كبيره من العوده الى المربع
الاول تطورات متسارعه تشهد الازمه
السودانيه في الايام الاولى من تمديد
الهدنه القصيره جوله جديده من الاشتباكات
في العاصمه الخرطوم صاحبها اعلان مفاجئ من
الجيش بتعليق مشاركته في مفاوضه جده دوي
اطلاق النار سمع في اماكن متفرقه من
الخرطوم قصف مدفعي في شمال ام درمان صاحبه
تحليق طيران الجيش الحربي في سماء المدينه
الانتهاكات المتكرره دفعت الجيش السوداني
الى ابلاغ الجانب السعودي والامريكي الذي
يبذل جهودا لتسهيل الحوار بتعليق مشاركته
في مفاوضات جده دون الانسحاب منها وفق
مراسله العربيه الجيش اوضح ان الهدنه لا
معنى لها بسبب انتهاكات الدعم السريع
المستمره للبنود المتفق عليها كما علل
تعليق مشاركته او مشاركته بان قوات الدعم
السريع رفضت الانسحاب من المستشفيات
والمرافق الطبيه ومنازل المواطنين
المفاوضات بين ممثلي القوتين العسكريتين
الكبيرتين في السودان كانت انطلقت قبل
ثلاثه اسابيع في جده وسط جهود سعوديه
امريكيه لتسهيل الحوار وافضل الى هدنه
قصيره امتدت لسبعه ايام في العشرين مما
يليو ثم مددت ليلى الاثنين الماضي لخمسه
ايام اخرى من اجل تسهيل مرور المساعدات
الانسانيه ومناقشه وقف دائما لاطلاق النار
في البلاد
[موسيقى]
الشعب السوداني
الى الانتباه الى مخدرات الفنون وحملات
التضليل
[موسيقى]
وللمزيد من متابع انضم الينا من القاهره
شريف محمد عثمان الامين السياسي لحزب
المؤتمر السوداني وعضو المكتب التنفيذي
لقوى الحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي ومن
الرياض الصحفي السوداني فتح الرحمن يوسف
اهلا بكما ضيفي العزيزين واسمحالي ان ابدا
مع ضيفي من الرياض الصحفي السوداني فتح
الرحمن يوسف سيد فتح الرحمن بدايه لماذا
قرر الجيش تعليق المحادثات في جده
وباعتقادكم الاسباب التي قدمها هل هي
اسباب وجيهه
طيب شكرا جزيلا السيد ابراهيم تحياتي لك
وتحيه للاخ شريف من القاهره والتحيه
للمشاهدين الاعزاء على امتداد البث
اعتقد ان الهدنه يعني ثبت بما لا يضع مجله
الشك
ان الهدنه تحاول قوات الدعم السريع
ان تمارس فيها منهجيه خفيه
والمناهجيه الخفيه هي منهجيه احتلال
مواطنين احتلال
موطن او مساكن المواطنين
للاحتماء فيها
وحمايه انفسها وكذلك ممارسه القنص وممارسه
الاختراقات بشكل افضل
يبدو ان هذه المنهجيه مرسومه بدقه وواضح
جدا خلال هذه الهدن ان هؤلاء قوات الدعم
السريع تنفذ هذا المخطط الى ان وصل الى
ابشع صوره الان لا حتى الان يتحدث الا عن
من قتل اليوم او غدا او بعد غدا
قبل يومين فقط تم اقتحام شخص مهم جدا وهو
الدكتور حسن الحسين وهو رجل عالم اكبر
عالم في هندسه الطرق تم اغتياله في بيته
في كافوري يعني عندما رفض الخروج والخنوع
الى اوامرهم
اطلق عليه الرصاص والقهوه صريعا على الارض
وهذا مثال بسيط ولكن الامس قصيره حتى الان
هنالك لاكثر من ثمانيه واربعين الف وحده
سكنيه داخل الخرطوم تم احتلالها وبالتالي
هذه منهجيه
تتبعها قوات الدعم السريع حتى يعني عندما
تكون هناك هدنه يمكن ان تفعل فعلها ولا
يدري عنها
المراقبون بينما عندما يرد الجيش يكون
واضحا ان الجيش خرق الهدنه باعتبار انه
يمارس احيانا يعني الاتحاد الافريقي قال
على لسان مدير اداره الصراع في مجلس السلم
والامن الافريقي بان الطرفين لم يلتزم
بالهدنه وبالتالي ما تقول عن قوات الدعم
السريع ينسحب ايضا على الجيش وهذا الطرف
محايد المفترض انه محايد
طبعا
الاتحاد الافريقي يعني هو للاسف الشديد
بطيء في الاستجابه
ورؤيته الاستراتيجيه قاصره جدا بدليل انه
لم يفعل اليات كثيره كان يمكن ان يفعلها
لايقاف الحرب من بدايتها وكان يمكن ان
يكون بعد ذلك هناك احتواء للصراع من خلال
يعني يعني
الاستفاده من مفاوضات جده ولكن احاول ان
يكونوا بمعزل عن فاضت جده وبذلك فشلوا
وهذا الفشل يحاولون
يتزرعوا بزرائع مختلفه منها ان هناك
خروقات يس هناك خروقات من الطرفين هناك
خروقات من الجيش وخرقات مقوات الدعم
السريع ولكن في ظني طخ ورقات القوات الجيش
السوداني هي ردا على
الممارسات القوات السريعه التي قد لا
يراها الاخرون طيب دعنا نستمع الى راي
الاستاذ شريف محمد عثمان من القاهره
تعليقك على ما تفضل به الاستاذ فتحي
الرحماني يوسف والاسباب التي ترى الاسباب
الحقيقيه التي ترى انها دفعت الجيش لتعليق
مشاركته في هذه المحادثات بجده
اولا مساء الخير عليكم مساء الخير على
الاستاذ عبد فتح الرحمن
ومساء الخير على كل متابعي قناه العربيه
صحيح اول لما حدث ما حدث اليوم مع صدر من
بيان من القوات المسلحه باعلان تعليق
مشاركتها في مفاوضات جده وساعددت في ذلك
عدد من الاسباب اعتقد ان هذا قرار ايضا هو
قرار موسف صراحه بالنسبه
للرغبه السودانيين والاعمالهم في ان تصل
هذه المحادثات الى نتائج ملموسه تعالج
القضايا التي من اجلها تم توقيع هذه
الاتفاقات بدا من الاعلان المبادي ومن ثم
التوقيع على اعلان الهدنه وتمديدها لخمسه
ايام اخرى من الواضح انه في عجزتان في
الالتزام بهذه بهذه الهدنه وفي هذا الوقت
يجب علينا ان ندفع الطرفين الذين صمماه
اليه المراقبه لهذه الهدنه حكومه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وحكومه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
ايضا بان يعرضوا تغاريرهم على الطرفين وان
يعملوا على ضغط الطرفين بكل الوسائل
المتاحه من اجل الالتزام بما تم التوضيح
عليه وما تم الاتفاق به في هذه الهدنه
والهدنه الممدده من اجل لا تتمكن الجهات
التي
تستفيد من هذه الهدنه بالنسبه لمساعدات
الانسانيه التي حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتمكن
السودانيين في مناطق عديده في ولايه
الخرطوم في ولايه غربي دارفور في ولايه
وسط دارفور وايضا في جنوب دارفور هذه
الولايات لم تستفيد من هذه الله هدنه حتى
هذه اللحظه بسبب الخروقات المستمره لهذه
الهدنه السؤال سيد شريف من يتحمل مسؤوليه
هذه الخروقات الجيش يتهم قوات الدعم
السريع بانه كما تحدث الاستاذ فتحي الرحمن
بانه يقوم باحتلال المنازل يقوم بقنص
الناس يقوم بمحاوله مسك الارض واستغلال
هذه الهدنه لكن في المقابل الناس في
السودان كانت تنتظر ان ينطلق الدخان
الابيض من جده لكنها فوجئت باستمرار
انطلاق سحب الدخان الاسود في العاصمه
وباقي الولايات السودانيه
بالتاكيد طبعا هم القوات المسلحه في اكثر
في
نشاطها خلال مثلا كل يوم هي بتنشر وبتعدد
انتهاكات قوات الدعم السريع وكذلك قوات
الدعم السريعه كل يوم تعدد انتهاكات
للقوات المسلحه وايضا نستمع الى افادات من
السودانيين الموجودين في العاصمه الخرطوم
في الولايات السودان المختلفه التي تتعرض
لهذه لهذه الحرب اللعينه نستمع الى
افاداتهم احيانا كثيره يكون الانتهاكات من
جانب الدعم السريع وايضا في احيان كثيره
تكون الانتهاكات عبر ضرب مدفعي او
بالطيران من القوات المسلحه من الواضح ان
هذه ان الحرب ما لم تكن هناك اليه مراقبه
محكمه من الواجب الان هو البحث سبل تطوير
اليات اليات المراقبه من اجل الزام الزام
الطرفين بان يلتزم ان المشكله في اليات
المراقبه ام وجود رغبه حقيقيه لدى
المكونين العسكريين لحقن دماء السودانيين
يعني المشكله هي يعني اذا شفتني شفتني او
اذا ما شفتني خلاص بطلق النار ام انه يجب
ان يتحلى الطرفان بالمسؤوليه لانه هذا
الموضوع موضوع خطير اذا ما استمر
بالتاكيد هما اولا من الطرفان لم يتعامل
مع كل القضيه السياسيه ولازمه السياسيه
الراهنه في السودان منذ ثوره ديسمبر
المجيده نفذوا عدد من العربات في مواجهه
هذا الانتقال والتحول المدني الديمقراطي
بدا بفضل الاعتصام ومن ثم انقلاب 25
اكتوبر لم يتعاملوا مع كل قضيه سلامه
السودان واستغراره بقدر مسؤول حقيقه هم
ارتكبوا عدد من الاخطاء خلال الفتره
الماضيه وما زالوا يرتكبوا العديد من
الاخطاء لكن نحن الان مدركين لان الطرفين
لا يمتلكان الاراده الكافيه لاعلان وقف
هذه الوقف هذه الحرب لكن على جهود
السودانيين والسودانيات في الداخل برفض
هذه الحرب هذه القوه المدنيه التي اتخذت
هذا هذا الخيار هذا سيساهم في الضغط على
القوات المسلحه والضغط على القوات الدعم
السريع وايضا على شركاء السودان من
المجتمع الدولي والاقليمي وايضا دول
الوساطه المملكه العربيه السعوديه وحكومه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عليهم من
يبذلوا مزيد من الجهود في مسارين المسار
الاول في ممارسه ضغوط السياسيه على
الالتزام بهذه الهدنه وايضا البحث سبل
تطوير اليات المراقبه ونشر التقارير
دعنا نستمع الى التعليق من السيد فتح
الرحمن
يعني له تاريخ طويل بهذه النزاعات لكن هذه
النزاعات لم تكن يوما في قلب العاصمه
الخرطوم وبالتالي هذا يجعل الكثير من
السودانيين يشعرون بحاله من الرعب برايك
تداعيات وقف هذه المحادثات
واستغلال محادثات جده كيف يمكن ان تنعكس
على واقع السودانيين
طيب شكرا جزيلا شكرا لك وللاخ الشريف انا
طبعا يعني اتفق مع اخي شريف في حقيقه
الحرب هي عباسيه
ومساله ايقاف الحرب هي مساله مطلوبه
والانسانيه وهذا لا شك فيه طبعا الهدنه تم
تعليق
المفاوضات ولكن
سيكون المسار يعني مفتوح اعتقد ذلك ولكن
اختلف مع اخي شريف جزئيات مهمه جدا نحن
هذه الجزيئات خليني انطلق من ما قلت به
انت الان يا سيدي ابراهيم بلطه لاول مره
تندلع حرب في الخرطوم وهذه هي هذا هو
المحك يعني يعني يجب الان ان لا نتحدث عن
طرفين من من
[موسيقى]
الظلم بمكان
نتحدث عن طرفين لابد ان نتحدث عن حاجه
اسمها قوات الجيش السوداني المؤسسه
الوطنيه القوميه التي التي تضم في اجنحتها
جميع الناس وقبائل السودان بخلاف قوات
الدعم السريعه التي هي هي مكون قبلي بحته
وحتى قادته يعني
انا لم ارى مؤسسه قوميه تحترم نفسها يكون
القائد ونائب ونائب نائبه والى ان نصل الى
20 او 30 نكون من بيت واحد من بعدها اولاد
عمومه وكذا هذا اصلا يعني تركيبه كانت في
في يعني تركيبه كانت غير سويه ابدا وغير
منطقيه ولكن لملايين نتحدث عن طرفين
يجب ان نتكلم عن قوات الجيش السوداني وهي
ليست البرهان يجب ان نتكلم عن القوات
السودان قوات التي دائما نقول هي عمرها
اكثر من 100 عام وهي نتائج لنواه الدفاع
قوه الدفاع السودان التي نرى السودان
بسببها الاستقلال
لا يمكن ان نقلنا نقول الطرفين ونحطها
بالتساوي مع قوات ماليشيه للاسف الشديد
انا كنت احترمها الى عهد القريب لكن الان
لا احترمها الان لها الان كيف يمكن ان
نتحدث عن خروقات
وعسكريه واضحه وهي ترتكب افزع جرائم في
الدنيا وافزع جرائم انسانيه يا رجل الان
يتم الاغتصاب يتم اللعب والسرقه احتلال
البيوت
مستشفيات تتحول الى سكنات عسكريه
الجامعات دمرت المكتبات العلم النقطه
الاولى هل هل في انتهاء اكبر من ذلك هل
بعد كل هذا الجرم الكبير نتحدث عن طرفين
انا اعتقد في هذا صم يا اخي شريف واعتقد
اخر شيء اخر صحيحا هناك حتى الانقلاب الذي
نتحدث عنه انقلاب 25 ابريل
جزء منه لماذا لماذا انقلبت عليه انقلبت
عليه الان
للاسف الشديد كانت قوه الحريه وانا لا
اقول كل القوه لكن اقول بعض افراد قوه
الحريه والتغيير قال لهم
اقتحم المعنى في اشعال هذه الفتنه وهذا
الذي يحدث الان لانه حدث ما بين القوات
الدعم السريه
الافراد يعني ما اتى بهذه الحرب الى
الخرطوم لاول مره في تاريخ السودان يعني
يحدث يعني نحن شهدنا 50 سنه عراق بين
اخواننا في جنوب السودان وفي السودان يعني
لم تصل طلقه واحده حتى الى على بعدي الف
المتر من الخرطوم السيد فتح الرحمن يعني
قليله تناولت عدد كبير احمل بكل صراحه لو
سمحت لي السيد ابراهيم وحمل والله قوه
الحريه والتغيير خاصه الذين وضعوا يدهم
على ايدي هذه الان هم يعتبروا نفسهم
نخبوين ويعتبروا نفسهم سياسيين وهو يعتبر
نفسهم مفكرين
السيد شريف محمد
يتحمل وزرها بالمقام الاول مع قوات الدعم
السريع هؤلاء الذين ينتمون الى قوى الحريه
اتهامات مباشره لقوات الدلع يعني لقوات
الحريه والتاريخ والحريه والتغيير بانها
ربما في العالم تبدي رغبتها بوقف اطلاق
النار لكن في السر هي تدعم وتشجع قوات
الدعم السريعه للاستمرار في هذه المواجهه
في اكثر من مره صدرت هذه الاتهامات هو قال
بانه قوات الجيش هي قوات نظاميه لديها
تاريخ عريق بينما قوات الدعم السريع مكونه
من قبائل وتركيبتها غير سويه تقوم باغتصاب
بالنساء وقتل العلماء كيف تردون على كل
هذه الاتهامات
اولا شكرا يعني اعتقد انه ضيفك برضو عوره
عدد من المعلومات غير غير صحيحه وغير هو
بنفسه فيك في في معرض حديث وقال انا كنت
احترمها حتى وقت غريب من انشا هذه القوات
حتى وقت غريب اعضاء مجلس السياده الفريق
ياسر العطاء والفريق كباشي كان يؤدون
التحيه لقاعده الدعم السريع وبحكم رتبته
او منصبه ووظيفته هذه القوات من انشاها
ومن عمل منها امعاءها طيله هذه السنوات هي
هي النظام الباي ومن ثم القائد الجيش عبد
الفتاح البرهان وقضيه توحيد الجيوش نفسها
لم تكن قضيه عبد الفتاح البرهان ولم تكن
قضيه القوات المسلحه هذه القضيه وهذا
الجندي هي من طرحته القوى المدنيه وقدمت
في سبيل ذلك تضحيات عظيمه حتى وصلنا الى
صيغ متوافق حولها حول حول عمليه الدمج
والاصلاح اما الحديث عن عن محاوله الصاق
هذه هذه الفديه وهذه الكذبه هذه الكذبه من
اطلقها ومن عمل على الدعايه والتسويق لها
والت هي فلول النظام البعيد منذ فتره قبل
حتى حتى اندلاع الحرب في 15 ابريل كنا
نستمع الى هذه الى هذه الدعايه الكاذبه من
عناصر بارزه من عليكرتي ومن انس عمر ومن
الجزولي بمحاولات الربط هو الحريه
والتغيير مع مع قوات الدعم السريع وهذا
الحديث ايضا هو مردود غير صحيح هو الحريه
وتغيير كانت تعمل بشكل دائم متصل من اجل
معالجه الخلافات والتباينات ما بين
المسلحه وما بين القوات الدعم السريع كما
تعمل عليها الان نحن الان مستمرين في بذل
الجهود لدينا التواصل مستمر ودائم مع قاده
القوات المسلحه لدينا تواصل مستمر نحن
ننظر للاهداف العليا والبلادنا ننظر الى
هذه القضايا الثانويه وعموما بشكل عام قد
قوات الدعم السريع في التوقيع في هذا
الاتفاق الذي وقع في مدينه جده وقع من
جانب القوات الدعم السريع وتم التوقيع
بجانب قوات القوات القوات المسلحه هذا
الوضع هو وضع معقد فيه
قانونيه بسبب قانون الدعم السري انشاه
النظام البيت في العام 2014 والتعديل 2017
كل هذه الامور يجب وضعها في الحسبان نحن
الان امام اسباب بامكان كل كل الناس ان
يوصفوا الانتهاكات والجرائم لكن هذا لن
يفيد السودانيين الذين يعيشون الان تحت
طائله الحرب السودان يحتاجون الان الى
اليات محدده للوصول لصيغه متوافق حولها
توقف هذه الحرب وتستعيد مسار الله الحيه
السياسيه ساعود ساعود ساعود للدور المكون
المدني والاحزاب السياسيه هذه الحرب هذه
النقطه وهذه الاتهامات ايضا تنسحب على
الجيش المتهم بانه يتعرض لضغوطات من
القيادات الاسلاميه في داخل الجيش
وبالتالي هي لا ترغب بان يتم التوصل
للاتفاق وان يبقى ربما تبقى قوات الدعم
السريع شريك للجيش وان تعود الامور الى ما
كانت عليه وايضا هناك اتهامات بانه فكره
الجيش بتسليح المدنيين هي فكره خطيره يعني
حتى حاكم اقليم دارفور دعم صراحه كل
مواطني دارفور لشراء اسلحه كلاشنكوف
لحمايه منازلهم وبالتالي هذه الدعوات من
الجيش الى اين تتجه بالبلاد سيد فتح
الرحمن
شكرا جزيلا اخي ابراهيم وشكرا جزيلا اصل
ايضا اخي شريف انا اختلف مع اخي شريف فيما
قال هو تحدث الان وانا احترم كنت احترم
قوات الدعم السريع لوقت قريب لماذا لانها
كانت كانت تخدعن بانها هي تقف وتنحاز الى
الشعب السوداني لماذا احترمها احترمها
لانها كانت تدعي انها ستحمي الحريه
والتمقراطيه وهذه الشعرات التي حتى الان
لا نرى لها اي وجود هذا هذا لماذا انا
احترمه لكن اذا تحدثنا عن مساله القوه
الحريه والتغيير نحن انا اتابعه او
اتابعها متابعه دقيقه ولابد ان نكون شجعان
نعترف في الاخطاء لنصحح الاخطاء اذا لم
نكن شجعان لن تقوم لهذه البلاد قائمه ابدا
اقول الحريه والتغيير انا دائما لا اقول
كل القوه هناك اناسا اعلمهم جيدا ويعملون
بصدق ولكن انا اعلم ان هناك واعرف كثير
هنا يعرفون ان بعضكم الحريه والتغيير يعني
للاسف الشديد صنعت هذا الشكل من
الهزال وهذا الشكل من كنت اود ان اسمع
سياسيا
في نقطه مهمه خلينا نكسب الوقت موضوع يعني
الضغوط التي يتعرض لها الجيش ايضا من
القيادات الاسلاميه هل يمكن ان تنفيها
طيب انا انا في هذه الحته للاسف الشديد
نحن نعلم جيدا
نعلم انه النظام البيض هو نظام يعني افسده
كويس يعني ما في مشكله انه هناك غطاء يمكن
ان يحاكم لكن انا للاسف الشديد وهذه لابد
ان اعترف فيها هؤلاء يجاوبوا بسياسه
الانتقام والتشفي وكذا يعني ما جاوب
بسياسه اداره الازمه لو جاوب السياسه
الاداره السياسه اين الخلل ويصلح
ويحاكم الفاسد وان شاء الله يقطع رقبته ما
في مشكله يا اخي نحن مشكلتنا في كيف يكون
الكلام صحيح كيف نحاكم يعني حكم العادل
كيف نقيم العدل كيف يعني كيف
نحاول ان لا ننصرف الى يعني هم انصرفوا من
البدايه انصرفوا بدل يتجهوا
جواب
لكن دعنا نعود
رئيسيه
نقطه الرئيسيه انه اعلان الجيش بانه علق
المفاوضات او مشاركته في المفاوضات لكنه
مستمر في البقاء في جده كيف يمكن فهم هذه
الاشاره واسمع الاجابه من السيد شريف ثم
اعود لاستمع لوجهه نظرك حول هذه النقطه
طيب نقول شكرا تاني مره تانيه انا حقيقه
هو طبعا يعني من اجل هذه الخط وهذه الحرب
عمل عليها لمده شهور طويله هم الاسلاميين
هذا الامر موثق تماما وموثق في في
فيديوهات في رسائل صوتيه في حملات ممنهجه
تحط على هذه الحرب صرح غاده الاسلاميين
بانهم اذا ذهب الناس الى الاتفاق الاطاري
هم سيشعلوا هذه الحرب هذا الكلام قالوه
صراحه حتى الوسطاء الموجودون الان في
مدينه في مدينه جده حكومه المملكه العربيه
السودانيه عبر سفيرها وحكومه الولايات
المتحده عبر سفيره هم كانوا شركاء في هذه
المناقشات وهم يعلمون تماما من هي الجهه
التي دفعت هذه البلاد دفعت نحو نحو الحرب
هذه الضغوط تعرضت لها القوات المسلحه ونحن
هذا الامر ايضا ناقشناه بكل وضوح مع
سودانيين وسودانيات وسائل الاعلام وقبل
اندلاع هذه هذه الحرب هذه المزال التانيه
فيما يخص هو صحيح انه ما زال الوفد القوات
المسلحه وكما اشرت ان هذا تعليق والتعليق
هو لمناقشه التفاصيل محدده في حاله
الالتزام بحسن يتم العوده الى طاوله
المباحثات
جيد هذه القضايا العالقه
هذه الساعات هل هناك امل بالعوده الى
المحادثات من جديد ووفق اي معطيات
وانا انا اعتقد اعتقد اعتقد ان هناك مجال
انه يكون هناك عوده للمفاوضات ولكن بمنظور
جديد انا اعتقد ما هو التي طرحها هذه
المفاوضات اعتقد انهما علموا جيدا ان هناك
خلل وصغره ونحن ذكرناه بكم مقابله عندكم
هنا في القناه اللي هي مساله مساله انسحاب
انسحاب قوات الدعم السريع من المستشفيات
كيف تعالج الناس كيف تمرر المساعدات
الانسانيه وانت تحتل مكانهم وانت تختطف
حتى الكوادر الطبيعيه واختطفوا وهذا ورد
في بيان الجيش واضح يعني
ورد في الحال نحن نحن نحن انا انا اعتقد
انه من الاهميه بمكان ان ينسحب قوات الدعم
السريعه من بيوت الناس وينسحب من
المستشفيات ومن الجامعات
ويبطلوا النحب والرعب ادخلوه في نفوس
المواطنين شكرا كيف وصلت
شكري لشريف محمد عثمان الامين السياسي
لحزب المؤتمر السوداني وعضو المكتب
التنفيذي لقوى الحريه والتغيير المجلس
المركزي كان معنا من القاهره وايضا الشكر
موصول لضيفي من الرياض الصحفي السوداني
فتح الرحمن يوسف
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات